how to convince people to buy in retail
so I got a great question front of my
youtube viewers love you guys Mayra who
wrote in to say what if you work in
retail how would I convince people they
need an item I work at Armani and I need
to sell two to three items per
transaction this is a great question and
having dealt with a lot of salespeople
at I'd malls and in retail outlets I've
seen the worst I've seen a few people
who do it really well so I wanted to
share three quick tips with you on how
to sell better in retail number one
actually care this might sound crazy for
but for some reason nobody actually does
this actually care about your customers
okay when somebody walks in the door if
I'm walking into your Armani store I
don't want you just seeing the money in
my pocket okay I want you seeing me
I want your goal to be when people come
into your store your goal is not to sell
them anything your goal is to make your
customer happy that's a different
mindset because too many people come in
and who's trying to sell you stuff and
you haven't even listened to my store
and listen to what I'm all about and
care what I'm trying to do why did I
walk in that store do you even know
probably not so maybe you want to get an
understanding of that before you try to
sell me something that's the big shift
that's why most of the salespeople they
don't have a lot of great success
because they don't care you want to ask
me questions when I walk in learn about
me ask me what I'm interested in ask me
why I walked into this store right find
out a little bit about me so that you
can make recommendations because here's
the thing okay you might be an expert
you might be and I hope you are right
you're an expert at picking out clothes
for men and women that fit the Armani
style okay you might look at me and say
to yourself I know exactly what this guy
needs you know you need to get this tie
and this shirt these pants is going to
look amazing but if you approach me and
I get to feel like you're trying to sell
me stuff even if you have the right
recommendations even if the stuff that
you're trying to sell me is the right
thing
for me and and if I tried it on I would
be amazed by the walk out the store with
five items even if that's the right call
if you come and you're trying to sell me
stuff and I get the wrong vibe from you
I'm walking out
I'm not buying from you because you're
trying to sell me and because you don't
care about me so that's number one
actually care about your customers
number two let them touch it there's a
certain fear that people have in buying
stuff that may be a little bit outside
their comfort zone and and you may know
that hey this is the right thing for you
you know you feel like after listening
to me and after hearing my challenges
and what I'm looking for you make the
right recommendation say this is what
you need say you're so you try to sell
me a ring okay you're trying to sell me
this ring you're trying to sell me this
ring and say you know what this is the
right ring for you and I look as a guy
you know I don't like how chunky it is
and how my reflection comes off and the
lighting and you know I don't think it's
gonna be a good fit for me if you really
believe that after listening to me and
knowing who I am
and caring about me that this is the
best thing for me you're not just trying
to sell me stuff you actually caring
about me then get me to try it on get me
to put it on my finger like that just
encourage you just try it on just humor
me and try it on I think just to see and
then when I look at it they can you know
what you're kind of right I kind of like
it it makes a big difference
so whatever clothing item you're pulling
out accessory shirt jean whatever it is
get them to try on get them to touch it
get them to feel it this is the advice
of Harry Rosen who's a really successful
Canadian retailer made men's suits and
dresses some of the most successful men
in Canada and I think he's open in the
u.s. too but his secret was always to
get people to try it on he would look at
them understand them and get them to try
on the suit and once they did and they
felt it and he talked about it and they
could see how they move around in it
then they're much more likely to buy so
get them to touch it number three reduce
the risk as much as possible you want to
reduce the risk for somebody coming in
to buy if somebody is coming in and they
pick the right product you know you've
helped them with it but
they're a little reluctant just a little
word and say you know what maybe I'll
come back the chance of them coming back
are super low sometimes they do but it's
small minority people will actually come
back after they check it out you want to
try to get them all there on the spot
and again you're only doing this because
you believe that this is the right thing
for them after listening to their needs
so what I look for is how to reduce the
risk so for example somebody may say
they come in and they try on something
so you know what I like it but I want to
talk to my wife and get her opinion
before I buy maybe your store offers a
30-day money-back guarantee you can tell
them you know what for your convenience
you can you can buy now take it home in
your comfort of your own home try it on
show it to her going on a date see how
it works together and if it doesn't work
out come back you've got 30 days full
refund guarantee no questions asked and
so you're reducing the risk so it makes
it easier for me to say yes I'm buy it
on the spot one last note about being
successful in retail I was recently
buying the suit and I really wanted the
Calvin Klein suit I knew what I wanted I
checked out the styles and I wanted my
Calvin Klein suit and I walked into a
store and I asked you guys have Calvin
Klein suits and the guy tried to
understand what I was doing I was
looking for and provided me options but
he didn't have any Calvin Klein suits he
didn't sell and I my heart was set on it
and instead of trying to convince me of
why I need to get this other suit he
said you know what we don't have Calvin
Klein suits but the store three three
aisles down they'll sell it and they
have one on sale that might be a good
fit for you and so he sent my business
away to somebody else and I ended up
buying a suit from that store but I
always remember the guy who made that
referral and if I ever need anything
else I'm going to him first because that
guy cares he's not just a sales guy he
cares and so I'm going to buy from him
so remember to make more sales in retail
number one actually care number two let
them touch it and number three reduce
the risk and believe for those who
watching you want to see more videos
like this you can subscribe to the
channel
you can click on the link in the
description to support me and leave a
comment let me know what you think your
feedback means so much to me and I love
seem to come in so thank you and I'll
see you soon